era este el mensaje que se esperaba del
mandatario en un estilo bastante vacío y
mencionando solamente lo necesario
Hola Valentina en realidad vivimos
algunos dos días de tensión esperando
este pronunciamiento del presidente y al
final
él pasó mensajes que es que eran
importantes y que esperábamos aquí en
Brasilia pero no pasó esta mensaje de
forma directa la primera está conectada
los bloqueos de carreteras federales por
Los camioneros él dijo que los métodos
utilizados por su simpatizantes no
deberían ser los mismos métodos que
perjudican al país entonces de forma
indirecta dijo a su simpatizantes Que
salieran de las carreteras lo segundo es
de la transición Entonces aunque él no
dijo directamente no felicitó al ex
presidente Lula su jefe de gabinete
suministro de la casa civil cirruno se
encargó de pasar este mensaje a los que
vieron esta porque este justamente
estábamos esperando las palabras del
mandatario para saber que iba a pasar
con los manifestantes que hoy han estado
en las calles Pero además este mensaje
del presidente sirve para aliviar de
alguna manera la extrema polarización en
el país
Mire yo creo que la polarización
política en Brasil comen muchos países
democráticos occidentales es una nueva
realidad el bolsonarismo Aunque pierde
la presidencia con estas elecciones tuvo
58 millones de votos de electores
brasileros es una fuerza política que se
va a mantener y en el discurso de
bolsonaro él Menciona algunas algunos
factores de estos últimos días de las
elecciones Como por ejemplo el buen
resultado de los bolsonaristas en la
selecciones legislativas que muestra que
él tiene una preocupación con mantenerse
en el mundo político como un
representante de esta derecha que tiene
una fuerza Entonces yo no veo que se
acaba la polarización el gobierno del ex
presidente y ahora presidente
Lula va a enfrentar una oposición
organizada y una oposición fuerte en el
congreso y en la sociedad
habla Igual de seguir cumpliendo con la
Constitución Podemos esperar que haya de
alguna manera un proceso fluido de
transición porque había temores de que
el jefe de estado dificultará este
Empalme
Sí yo creo que cuando él dice que juega
dentro de las líneas de la Constitución
él habla sobre la posibilidad de los
rumores de una intervención de las
fuerzas armadas o de algo así más
radical en Brasil tenemos un decreto una
ley que regulamenta este periodo de
transición que garantiza que el gobierno
que entra tendrá acceso a los documentos
a todos los proyectos necesarios para
que tendemos una una una transición
positiva y el mensaje que pasó Ciro
Noguera que el vicepresidente de luz se
va a encargar de este proceso de
transición veo como positivo veo que el
mensaje de de lo constitucional nos
apunta que tendremos Sí una una
transición estable